do you guys think about when mothers
don't let their kids see their fathers
selfish I think I think those women that
do the scumbags to be honest it hurts
the child it manipulators as well and
they're abusing their position of power
in the situation I think that they
should go to jail I think that a woman
who does not let the dad see their kids
should face jail time I think that's how
serious they should take it because
you're putting your kid at every
statistical disadvantage you possibly
could by not letting them see their
father yeah the psychological
development as well by not having their
father around and and he's gonna cause
trauma down the line and I feel like the
one thing they forget is that the kids
grow up eventually you can tell them
that he was a deadbeat you can tell them
all these stories but one day they'll
grow up and they'll find out they'll ask
their dad for his side of the story I
mean how many kids does that happen to
you saw it happen to Kanye